وعيد متبادل بين روسيا واوكرانيا في البحر
الاسود مباشره بعد اعلانها توقف العمل
باتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب قالت روسيا انها
ستعتبر اي سفينه متجهه الى الموانئ
الاوكرانيه ناقله محتمله لشحنات عسكريه
وطرفا في الصراع واعتبرت جنوب شرقي وجنوب
غربي البحر الاسود مناطق خطيره للملاحه
الان ترد اوكرانيا وتقول ان جميع السفن
المتجهه الى موانئ روسيا او الموانئ
الاوكرانيه المحتله مؤقتا حسب وصف وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ستعتبر حامله باسلحه
وسيتم التعامل معها على هذا الاساس واضافت
ان التنقل سيحذر في شمال الشرقي البحر
الاسود ومضيق كيرشينيكال لم يكن في
الطرفان بالوعيد والتهديد فقد شنت روسيا
هجمات قالت انها استهدفت منشات عسكريه
ومخازن ذخيره في اوديسا وميكو لايف وهما
من اهم موانئ تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه اما
الرئاسه فقد قالت ان الهجمات الروسيه
استهدفت عمدا محطات الحبوب بهدف واضح هو
تدمير امكانيه شحن حبوب اوكرانيه اعتبرت
الهجمات الروسيه ردا على استهداف مسيرات
بحريه
الذي يربط بين روسيا وشبه جزيره القرم
التي ضمتها عام 2014 اكد الهجوم الدوره
المتزايده الذي اصبحت تلعبه المسيرات
البحريه الى جانب الجويه في هذه الحرب لم
يتوقف التصعيد في البحر الاسود واشتعلت
النيران قرب مدينه ستالي كريم جنوبيه شبه
جزيره القرم حيث مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي بسباس وتحدثت مصادر في شبه الجزيره
عن هجمات ومسيرات جويه وبحريه في مايو
الماضي دمرت روسيا اخر سفينه اوكرانيه
كانت تدعى
بميناء اوديسا فزادت كياف من اعتمادها على
المسيرات البحريه تنتج اوكرانيا مسيرات
بحريه وحصلت على اخرى ضمن المساعدات
العسكريه الغربيه ورغم امتلاك روسيا
اسطولا بحريا ضخما فقد بدات تعتمد ايضا
على المسيرات البحريه بدقتها في ضرب
الاهداف والانخفاض تكلفتها خصوصا البشريه
[موسيقى]